d'accord faisons ça
ce qui est si amusant avec she-hulk
c'est qu'il y a beaucoup de
camées inattendus hulk blonsky wong titania
[musique]
je tuerai pour toi megan l'étalon
oh tu es bien plus amusant que mon dernier
avocat megan est vraiment bon  acteur je suis un
grand fan comme si c'était fou
tu penses à cette énorme star mais megan
était juste géniale
je fais des choses révolutionnaires en
twerkant dans marvel et j'aime
me considérer comme une version de thanos
rappelez-vous juste à qui émission c'est en fait
chaque  l'épisode présente un casting fou de
personnes,
il y a tellement plus à venir dans ce
monde loufoque
[Musique]
tu m'as dit en face que tu
n'étais plus devenu l'
abomination  constitue un autre crime et
détruit totalement vos chances de libération conditionnelle,
bien
pas parce que
j'ai été forcé
de quitter ma cellule mais je suis revenu
de mon plein gré qui vous a forcé à
échapper à cette prison incroyablement haute sécurité sans être
détecté  ted un sorcier suprême
des arts mystiques et son nom est wong
juste
wong et sa présence sur internet est un
peu chaotique c'est soit
un sorcier qui vit à new york soit un
bibliothécaire qui vit au népal peux
tu le joindre oui jen c'est moi bien sur  je peux l'
atteindre j'ai envoyé un piège à soif
c'était une photo de moi avec un tas de
livres j'espère juste qu'il rappelle tu
sais si blonsky dit la vérité ce
gars l'a fait sortir de sa cellule de prison
et a probablement ruiné toute mon affaire
vous